this man has learned not to be too
trusting especially in social networks
he knows that lots of people he meets
there aren't people at all nuts finga
helps companies and governments in the
evaluation of big data in the course of
his work he came across social boss
social votes in social votes our
algorithms which inhabit social networks
and because they develop their own life
and take on a function in these networks
they seem a lot closer trustworthy and
more personal than someone off our
rhythms our mathematical formulae which
mimic humans a kind of marionettes
it sounds complex but looks finger says
it isn't
he's built a social bot yeah he hits my
spots a bot and I've created spot the
bot a Twitter account
we still haven't tweeted anything
nothing's happening on this account
because it's a fresh one I want to make
sure that this account comes to life
account some even comment he finds
everything a social bot needs on the
internet for example followers the more
fans he has the more genuine his account
sees a package of two and a half
thousand followers costs $39 but they're
all faked
now he's kidding out the social BOTS
with a face photo sharing sites provide
him with snapshots he can simply upload
to his Twitter profile
the same as news feeds which are freely
available on the net that's it I've
turned it on now we just have to wait
until things start working in solution
get this there are enough studies which
show that around 7% of the tweeps
profiles are clearly bot profiles which
are trying not to be recognized as such
they're social BOTS and they're not
allowed according to the Terms of Use
issued by Twitter and it's like but
social bots are very hard to an earth
usually it can't be done they do
everything to be accepted as people and
not recognized as machines 1,000 tweets
a minute wouldn't be a problem for a
computer but that would be too obvious
no person could manage that a spam
filter would kick in right away and
deactivate the profile
nuts finger is a quantum physicist and
as such he's well aware that not
everything is as it seems but what are
social BOTS actually used for but fazool
naturally BOTS try and exercise
influence by trying to convince people
to do something so I convinced them to
buy a product or to adopt a certain
opinion - of Twitter and other social
networks are having a growing influence
on political and economic decisions
that's why fraudsters want to manipulate
data and subtly steer opinion some are
discovered and removed but no one knows
how many are actually active in the
internet you can harm companies by
setting bots on though and it's very
hard later on to figure out who did it
and there's no effective protection yet
no stinger says he thinks social BOTS
will change the internet in his opinion
social networks will probably check the
identity of their users a lot more
thoroughly that means that in future
communication will be a lot less
anonymous and much more closely watched
but what's most likely I don't need to
be afraid of BOTS you need to be afraid
of people influencing you and that
should worry you whether there are BOTS
or not bots are a means of influencing
people
Fingaz had to travel to the US soon to
work at a social network company his
work will also deal with social BOTS
and the one he created it's already
posted more than 100 tweets so far he's
only got one follower but he's adding
the ones he bought slowly some no one
notices and at some time in the future
he'll simply turn it off